there are 41 whole words that you can
text using recorder the longest of which
are cabbage and baggage
there's loads of videos of people taking
things which aren't musical and making a
musical with the makeymakey so this
weekend we decided we take something
that was musical and make it do
something computery this is part of a
hackathon at Manchester one of the
sponsors had a challenge the most
ridiculous use of a texting API and
Paula decided to rig up a musical
instrument to a texting API so you have
you can text with only the musical notes
available we have a recorder connected
to a making a theme which we are using
as the input instead of a keyboard into
this laptop there's wires connected to
each of these finger holes and there's
an earth wire connected to the
mouthpiece with the makey makey you have
to be connecting one of those wires and
the earth at the same time to get input
into a computer if you're holding the
key is and then you blow into it and
connect the earth you can start typing
as you would with any other keyboard
except it's not keyboard it's a recorder
we numbered each of the holes and then
we change the file on the makey main key
so that when each of those holes it
touch it sends a string through the USB
with which holes were being pressed when
you touch the earth so for example we'll
send 0 1 and 2
to the computer because those are the
holes that I had covered very much for 2
we kept doing it just that way this
weekend to not annoy you ok
oh good send 0 1 and 2 because those
with the holes I had covered when I
press the F the only one that actually
plays a recorder sorry for my bad
recording
I'm not record a player sure those are
meant to be different notice that the
wires I'm a tendency to come out as you
can see they are purely duct taped on
bit of a technical issue with the duct
tape you can't be pressing gates
yeah you might work a bit better now see
what good is having so many numbers on
them how do you get coverage what
happens is that it sends all of the
numbers in a string in order you can
then write head an applet that will let
you take that string and switch on a
case statement to say what letter should
come from though so we chose to do it so
if you played an A then a statement
would say you've pressed 0 1 and 2 and
switch that so they were up 1a onto the
screen instead of showing you 0 1 & 2 I
was thinking you maybe make 0 a 1 B but
you're talking about the actual military
is alright yeah
causes 8 holes we could have used 8
factorial and had each one corresponding
to a different letter and covered all of
the letters and numbers and some
punctuation but we thought this way is a
bit more ridiculous and you know when
you've got a recorder covered in duct
tape
it's pretty ridiculous anyway so make
it's ridiculous as you can imagine a key
is sillerton Audrina it's runny Audrina
somewhere so there's a program on here
and in Audrina C which will send the
appropriate codes through this is a Java
file Java class record ramped up and in
the quarter input class they have this
switch name so switch lemon they just
recognizing the different notes so 0 1 2
for the a zero wants to be zero to the
sea once they've formed laser recognize
what no they are they can be fenced to
rush the program to be used so texting
or anything really I'm not a musician
I'm a computer scientist it was
difficult and we upset a lot of people
it's you in the morning at a hackathon
when they were trying to sleep going
will this work blow and oh oh we
squeaked etc but it does take quite a
while I'll be honest ok the longest word
that we can text is the word cabbage so
here we go so we got 0-2 which
represents C 0 1 2 representing a 0 1
twice representing 2 B's so you want to
again and 0 1 2 3 and then eat which is
a bit of a ridiculous one we're sure to
press 0 1 2 3 4 and 5 and there's quite
a few finger holes involved in that one
so we were actually sitting quite close
to the team that was sponsoring this
award and then they very quickly caught
on to what was going on and Paulin
became known as the girl with the
recorder and devotes a bit of a fanfare
for every event and that led on to Paul
actually winning the hacker forum for
that challenge her partner won and one
of the prizes were it was for Nexus
fours and a 5 foot banana so let's say I
have an important documents the
permission to to go to the moon to the
White House at that uh yeah I decided
why not put them all in